hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sonic Dreams collection
now this is a lost and old and abandoned
series of games found on a lost an old
abandoned Dreamcast made by a lost an
old abandoned game developer we didn't
know what he was really making when he
was stuffing all the children's souls
beanie the animatronic plushies ah so
this is supposed to be a totally legit
series of games that was found by a guy
after buying a Dreamcast on eBay but
it's full of games and actually Aaron of
the game grumps and egoraptor told me
that I needed to play it because he said
it was a trip into madness unlike
anything he'd ever seen before
so make my sonic was MJ studio's first
prototype with Sega Sonic OC creator MJ
Stewart once was committed to fans
self-expression they believed that Sonic
was versatile enough for every genre
even sci-fi make my son it was meant to
create and upload avatars for use with
ever dream guys to Sega net sadly no
future you guys hear that fire-breathing
this game it's not supposed to be uh
right in the head this this is this game
supposed to be weird so I'm in under the
OE hi
how's it goin Lucia the Hedgehog oh okay
oh this is normal oh god there's so many
levels of normal here ah they don't
exactly stay where I want to do let's
not have him do that thank you
fight whoa okay okay okay I'm sorry
Sonic oh oh oh
Sonic not doing so good eyes on ik yeah
there he's waving at me
oh he's staring into my soul the nobbies
waving OH
oh man oh wow Oh why I don't even get to
name it it just makes it up alien metal
McAlister the Hedgehog ruiji steal the
princess a jug night Nicholas Potter the
king Hedgehog oh my Oh flame the
immortal hedgy I like that one though
it's really good
hi hi hello I'm flame the immortal hedgy
aah oh crap let me just spank my taint
there a little bit there is this funny
Oh just fondling my balls okay
enough jokes about balls oh hey whoa hi
how'd it go in there
can I pose you so I can yes I can okay
today dreams collegues ensure indeed
okay hey kids I'm Sonic [ __ ] okay
everyone say hi to my OC flame the
immortal hedgy but ish oh tweet photo I
don't think I wanted tweet photo okay I
don't think I want to do that oh crap
it's actually doing it nah oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no okay all
right oh yeah okay oh so here hey uh are
you doing friend hello hello friend it's
your friendly neighborhood sonic are you
I don't think it likes me doing that in
case you didn't know flame the immortal
hedge EES rolling in it okay I'm gonna
leave now
wow it's fun I sure I'm glad that I
played that game boy I'm gonna play the
next one almost nothing is known about
Eggman origin there's no surviving
documentation from digging through the
code we can tell it was an MMORPG but we
have few everything in past the title
screen well oh god I'll give it a go
I'll give it a little go Rudy I'll see
what EDD man is all about
ah no network adapter is that yeah is
that so okay alright okay okay alright
bye I'll come back maybe I can like
unlock a network adapter somewhere here
sonic movie maker okay sonic movie maker
was many years ahead of its time
technically speaking M de Studio
envisioned a moviemaking program for
players who explore and share their
desires with the rest of the world
internal note suggests the second
executive pull the plug after learning
about some sonic movie makers darker
subplots oh I can only imagine what fans
would want to make about Sonic I can
only imagine I can only imagine time
okay here we go
I wonder if it really wants me to
connect my Twitter account cuz I don't
want to do that oh hi oh look they're
friends or maybe not everything else
seems to be destroyed oh this seems
awkward how to play would love to know
promo film are una película a steady
hand is the first step to a great film
okay once you're done filling walk
through the red exit door to show us
Sonic you're satisfied while grabbing a
prop of rap you can use the scroll wheel
to pull it or push it oh boy how much am
I gonna need to do that use the Iggy
Oh Sonic and his pals love touching
different props experiment to find out
who key let's not okay backyard scenario
welcome to Sonic Movie Maker oh oh oh no
oh no oh no oh okay hi Sonic hurry
how you doing okay what's this what is
this what is this what is this hey Sonic
how's it going
oh my looking good today looking good
today okay I'm gonna go now oh boy oh
boy oh boy it really worked
somehow it worked wait that's not my
movie is that the movie I made I think
that might be the movie I made okay
that's great movie case I'm watching it
oh yeah
oh man oh so God you're welcome Jack
pull me what do I know what a bullet
why do I want to pull it I pulled it
ah the the they're dancing they're
dancing they're they're dancing and I'm
just I'm just the prom night I don't I
don't want to film this I don't want to
film this I don't want any part of this
I want absolutely what is this what what
what is this crap ah ah why why is this
happening why is it happening
okay there you go all right here we go
be natural you're a natural
you're doing great you're doing great
you're doing great they're just dancing
the tonal this is dancing Oh
oh good oh good let's dance yeah that's
that's that's what it was that's what it
was over okay
all right bye-bye everybody goodbye
Oh No is there like a secret back here
Oh is there any way to escape the hell
of what I'm about to witness oh god is
there any way out of here
please tell me this is way out of here I
don't want to have to go in there I
don't have to go I don't have to see it
I definitely don't want to have to film
it and make movie out of it oh boy this
game sure was way ahead of its time
oh boy hi what the hell is that who the
hell are you what the hell are you were
you what are you
Oh should have you going near you Oh
what are you who do you I love tails but
I'm so shy Oh God okay okay cool things
Iggy
okay okay okay haha
okay all right there we go a little bit
of that little bit of this all right
right there
Oh tails you look so happy you're uh
you're coming with me tails
I got an Easter Egg to find that takes
me far away from whatever the hell is
going on that house hotel-motel whatever
I don't know just tails come with me
this looks even worth I'm dragging him
into the back of a dark alley with a
video camera I mean this can't look good
for me he's taking me to a trip
everything that was going on in there
the internet already has too much of
that I know you love tales so I brought
him for some reason don't know why here
we go Oh
thank you thank you no thank you
thank you seems bad smokey the bear
wouldn't appreciate none of this I mean
I was told and only me can prevent
forest fires but I'm pretty sure this is
the opposite of the intended effect it's
always best when you walk into a sonic
orgy to just burn the whole [ __ ] down
because there ain't no going back to
this ain't no going back it's gonna just
gonna take this
Maria no okay throw that in there and
just watch all this go down cuz oh boy
no one knows now no one knows there's an
orgy happening at all oh boy and these
these sad sods want to watch this movie
after it's done yay game when who ends a
sequel what is equal ah oh what is this
what is this what is this what is this
oh is that blood
oh no that's another piece of cake but
it seemed to have been coated in blood
what what am i doing well what am i
doing what why am I still doing it why
am i doing it well I don't have a camera
where's my camera
sorry oh no what the hell what the hell
what the hell ah
okay alright
ah there you go oh okay
Oh oh my god okay okay okay Oh what's he
gonna blow up
is he gonna blow up he's gonna blow up
isn't he always gonna blow up oh I'm not
done it's not done oh damn it oh god no
oh no no no what is that what is that
tails why are you there what is the
point of that oh no I didn't mean to put
that there
Oh God Oh God what do I do do I feed oh
wow
hi Sonic how are you you're looking good
this is weird this is really weird
hi Iggy I see you down there oh no no no
no no no no no no no no no oh oh oh he
didn't he ate him oh no no no eat this
oh no no no no no no no no okay
i'ma leave now oh wow okay a new classic
could it possibly get any worse could
there possibly be more mysteries done
Ravel
squirrel dove Sonic's dreams but other
horrors lie and wait for me what other
secrets are left to be found only one
way to find out and maybe special guests
can guide me through
sweet dreams